do me so welcome to the heavy spoilers
show I'm your host definition aka tiny
Dick Grayson and this video we're
breaking down a big Batman theory and a
lot of cool little updates on the film
this includes Easter eggs bat suit
details bat cave rumors and a lot more
we will be talking about some of the
plot leaks for the first hour of the
movie so if you don't want anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
grab now boost yourself out of year if
you enjoy the video then please punch
that thumbs up button and as always make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day
I'm keeping the intro very short so we
can get right into the news so sit back
shut the hell up thank you for clicking
this and let's get into the breakdown
okay so last Friday it was announced by
deadline that HBO max were working on a
show that would center around the Gotham
City Police Department movie maker Matt
Reeves is officially heading up the
project and the TV show will be a direct
tie-in with his up and coming Robert
Pattinson movie the show is currently
being written by Broadwalk Empire
creator Terence winter and according to
Deadline it will build upon the film's
examination of the corruption in Gotham
Terrance was also part of The Sopranos
so he's had a very esteemed career and
with this being an HBO property you can
expect high-quality production values
and incredible eight seasons and for
them to just completely ruin it in the
final three episodes I'll never forgive
you Dumb and Dumber now
this apparently is the first project as
part of Matt Reeves his overall deal
with Warner Brothers television so
there's a lot of other things that could
be coming our way down the line as I'm
sure you can tell I'm very excited as
there's a lot of things to look forward
to and just before we get into our
theory Reeves said this on the project
this is an amazing opportunity not only
to expand the vision of the world I'm
creating in the film but to explore it
in the kind of depth and detail that
only a long-form format can afford and
getting to work with the incredibly
talented Terence winter who's written so
insightful and powerfully about worlds
of crime and corruption is an absolute
dream and I also loved the heavy
spoilers show so clearly everyone is
very excited
and hopefully we get something akin to
agents of shield where the films
directly influence the events of the
show and more
now what this opens us up to is a lot of
possibilities and how they can build the
world around the movie we did hear a lot
of rumors circulating around the film
that in addition to penguin Riddler and
Catwoman
there would be appearances by Firefly
the Mad Hatter and even a hint at the
Joker and Harvey Dent when I first came
across those rumors I did think that
there may be far too many villains to
have in one film and didn't know how
Reeves would actually manage to pull off
all of the complexities that introducing
all these different aspects of the world
will entail I just brushed them to the
side as being potentially fake news
however in light of the TV show I think
that it gives us the perfect opportunity
to have a multitude of villains that can
have cameo like roles for the movie
before getting full scenes in the TV
show so when Gil Coulson aka the DA in
the film gets off by the Riddler and
again I did say spoilers we could get a
glimpse at Harvey Dent who then becomes
a fully fledged character in the HBO
mock show letting us get to know Harvey
on a personal level like never before
before he eventually becomes two-face if
you read the graphic novel series Gotham
Central which the show is reportedly
based upon then you'll know there's a
lot of potential avenues they can take
it I've not read the entire collection
but I did get up to volume 3 and I
absolutely loved it there's an
incredible mr. freeze story in there
that would be ice to see play out and
live-action and yet hopefully it'll be
hot enough to under even the coldest of
hearts
now another theory that I have is that
this may actually start off as a prequel
initially before becoming fully
integrated into the universe seasons
down the line this would be similar to
Gotham in that it would discuss why
there was a need for Batman in the first
place and it would also allow for a lot
of characters to get their origin story
we have a lot of reports around the
movie that say the initial crime scene
that was filmed in London was actually
the murder of the mayor this is why so
many news fans were there and why Bruce
Wayne himself visited the location there
were further leaks given that said the
giant Cathedral that was being built was
for his funeral which would see an
attack by the Riddler so lots of things
centered around
the mayor and I think that if there was
a TV show we could actually see his time
in power before his supposed to death I
mean how good would it be to see the
character that was so hated he was
murdered by his own citizens just being
a complete douche he could become the
face of corruption and the show could
really explore why the mayor pretty much
led to the downfall of Gotham and thus
Batman needed to step in in order to try
and save the city from itself absolutely
love prequel stories when we see the bad
guys that we now had horrendous fates
operating out and about and better call
Saul has done this to great effect so I
actually think that the mayor may become
one of the big villains in the TV show
and we will see a young up-and-coming
Gordon having to deal with this Jeffrey
Wright is of course no stranger to HBO
shows and he's done a great job in
Westworld recently I really think
there's a lot to look forward to and
obviously I'll keep you up to date with
the show as we get more news on it now
before we get into the rest of the video
I just wanna let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the MCU infinity
saga box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to being with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts in the video in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of July and
the set will be shipped out from the
into ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part okay
so I just want to talk about some new
Easter eggs that were discovered in
regards to the Batsuit now first off
shoutouts Harrison Jolly for sending me
this and after looking over the picture
I think the guy has got a completely
bang on so on the Batsuit we can clearly
see two pipes that run down the arms and
connect to his gauntlets with a sort of
exhaust at the bottom as we know the a
track ality and deception are powerful
agents of the League of Shadows and
Batman loves to use gas to escape or
cloud his enemies eyes these pipes
definitely seem like they're built to
deploy gas rather than the typical bombs
that the character uses and bats off to
anyone who spotted this in addition to
these twitter account the bat source
also put together a number of Easter
eggs that have been spotted so I just
thought I'd go over them in case you
haven't come across them so far so the
news vans that we saw of Gotham action
news is
you called back to the 89 Batman film in
which they popped up supplying news
reports on the state of the city this
itself was a reference to the Dark
Knight Returns graphic novel and it's
good to see you popping back up here as
we know there are reports that Michael
Keene is in talks to return to the cowl
for the flashpoint movie so who knows if
they decide to actually tie this into
the DCU
we could have this as a sort of retcon
origin story for the character that sets
up the events of Flashpoint we also have
a tri-corner cab and this is a reference
in the tri corner of Gotham which is a
port area the docks often appear on
Batman pieces as a place where shady
dealings go down and it's nice that
they're at least referencing this who
knows the characters may even visit it
and we could get the tri corner as a
location in the HBO Mac show the next
one comes from Batmobile designer ash
Thorp who confirmed that the engine at
the back of the car was deliberately
built to resemble a bat and I did kind
of lose it a bit when I saw this it
shows how in-depth they're going with
the design of the car and it was a
really cool early stir egg that I didn't
even notice so congrats to whoever
spotted it the final Easter Egg is one
that we pointed out in videos so far but
I thought I'd go over it just to be
thorough that is a little penguin shape
in the a of the logo itself which is of
course a reference to Colin Farrell who
will be playing the infamous crime boss
so yeah lots of cool little things there
and lastly we're gonna be doing some
debunking just to close out the show now
this comes from subreddit DCE leaks and
it apparently tells us some little
things about the Batcave it's made the
rounds recently and the main part of the
post says first of all the Batcave
it's my understanding that Warner
Brothers have taken the unusual step of
buying a large warehouse in London to
construct this set rather than just
renting a property so I personally
suspect this Batcave will feature
prominently throughout the main trilogy
and might even be used as a shooting
location and template for any future
Batman properties because those caves
are pretty damn expensive to build the
Batcave itself will be made up of a
large chamber surrounded by three ledge
floors / tiers each connected by a metal
added stairs and a central elevator
platform and
helicopter will be parked on the top
tier I'm assuming that means this new
Batcave will have a ceiling roof that
can open up - which would be something
new for sure the post then went on to
say that the Joker wouldn't be featuring
in any capacity which does contradict
other reports we've heard however the
user has since deleted their account
which normally means that the leaks were
fake and they got called out on it so
just dip their head in the sand this
happened with the DC phantom leaks last
week after James Gunn did it and it
seems to be a pattern of behavior
whenever people get shut down so I would
say that if this post is integrated into
any of the reports going forward just
don't take it as a given because it's
probably being made up due to the
actions of the poster it's a shame
there's so many leaks knocking about bub
you know we're trying to be the world's
greatest detective here so I'll always
do my best to tell you when when
something just sounds a bit fishy anyway
that's the news this week and as always
make sure you subscribe as every week we
drop new videos on Batman same bat-time
same bat-channel
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the series art theories and
everything mentioned in the video so
make sure you comment below and let us
know if you enjoyed this and want
something else to watch that makes you
check out our debunking of the DC
phantom leaks which will be linked at
the end we want to support the channel
and get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button and
you can also come chat to us on our
discord link below or add heavy spoilers
on Twitter thanks for making it until
the end of the video you've been the
best I've been definition and I'll see
you next time take care I don't know
what that was
[Music]
you
[Music]